I love people like this.
This woman is asking about the psychological impact
that leaving your baby right after they're born
to go to work has on a child for the rest of their lives.
And she's right. There's actually a lot of bogus studies out there
showing that it's perfectly fine to put your child in daycare.
And again, biased agenda.
One of my favorite clinical cycle analysts,
her name is Doctor Erica Commissar,
speaks on the matter of leaving your children to go back to work
better than anyone I've ever heard explain it.
Mind you, she's done the studies.
She has over 30 years of experience.
And she's not the only doctor that speaks out on this.
She has researched neuroscience, epigenetics,
attachment theory, behavioral science,
and neuropsychology, which is apparently all of those fields combined.
And she wrote a book called Being There
Why Prioritizing Motherhood in the First Three Years Matters.
The biggest neurological growth spurt that a human has
is within the first two years of their lives.
She also discusses that women leaving babies and daycares,
or even at home while they go to work
has created two generations of people with attachment issues.
That is the childhood trauma that is now LED to generations
like millennials, Gen Zers,
and the ones below us having zero ability to date,
find companionship, find partner.
Everyone wants to blame social media and dating apps,
when in really, when reality,
it started way younger than that.
When we were born because our mothers left us to go back to work,
because that is what our culture taught us was right to do.
And based off her research,
she has also ranked the types of different care
that you can give your children
from least to best, daycare being the absolute worst.
Then she talks about nannies,
and then she talks about having, like,
a kinship nanny, meaning someone that's related to you.
Like, maybe your mother helps you watch the baby while you go to work.
When I attempted to work after my first child,
it was my niece, who's, like,
my sister. She also gives you, like,
a neurological breakdown
of what happens to children when you leave them,
specifically babies, like when they're newborns.
We tend to go back to work at three months.
That child should still be,
and I say should, not in a judgy way,
but it should still be on the breast of the mother.
And she claims that they should not be left for more than,
like, an hour,
sometimes two hours, max.
We think that because babies are small and cannot communicate
that they're fine when we leave them,
when in reality, they have these deep sense of abandonment issues.
Because what most people don't realize
is that the only reason humans are born so early
is because our heads out grow the mother's body.
So we're carry primates when we come outside, earthbound,
outside of our mothers.
We are still supposed to be attached to them for about two years.
That is why many cultures
wear their children until they're two years old.
She also claims that this is why mothers are so unhappy in America
and why babies cry so much,
because we are taught to let them cry it out.
We're taught to put them down,
that they don't have to be on us.
When in like Eastern European countries and Africa,
mothers hold their babies all the time and babies don't cry as much.
I co slept with my children
and I can tell you
that there was a night and day difference between my children
and even my second child that I did more with since he was born
compared to my first, because I Learned from my previous situation.
She also discusses that how children under the age of one
have to be soothed moment to moment,
meaning the minute they cry,
you are supposed to pick them up and sue them.
And this is how we regulate their cortisol levels.
This is how we become.
I believe she calls it a buffer between their stress and them
and how children are very dependent on their caregiver
to regulate their emotions for them.
Again, this is why I do not agree with the whole cry it out method
that the boomers taught us.
Now, we didn't know the impact of what the Boss Babe movement would do
or having women leave their Children go back to work until,
of course, generations later,
because we were the Guinea pigs,
but now they have the actual effects of it.
They have millions of people and Gen Zers and millennials
and even some boomers where they can actually take data from
and figure out why it was so detrimental
to leave our children at home
to go back to work at such an early age.
Now, you cannot sue the baby moment to moment when you're in a daycare.
And I know this first handed
because I worked at a learning center in East Texas for like,
six months. It was terrible.
It was horrible. We had two people working in a room with 13 children,
which I believe was even illegal at that time.
It broke my heart every day
because there was no way
I could comfort and soothe every single baby that was there.
And I could absolutely witness firsthand
the effects that it was having on their development.
That is why it is important to have one person
caretaking for this baby, and ideally,
it's the mother. She also discusses this thing called share the care,
I guess, that they do in California,
where they basically,
parents will share the cost of a nanny to make it more affordable
so that they have maybe three kids with one nanny.
And she discusses how that's better than,
for instance,
putting someone in a daycare where they don't have as much attention
between The caregiver and 13 other children.
I'll add another video with some of her clips,
but basically,
I also would like to add that common sense comes into play here.
I don't like giving my child to anyone.
Because at the end of the day,
it was my brain that chemically reacted
when I got pregnant and then gave birth.
It was my amygdala and prefrontal cortex that swelled and changed
so that I could be more attentive to my child.
Even in the case of my husband watching my, like,
Newborn children, I never wanted to offend him,
but I would always be like,
hey, are you watching him?
Hey, is he near a pool?
Can you see your peripheral vision?
Is he there? Because a mom can see literally everything.
It is innate and biological.
No one can ever love or watch your child better than you can
after you birth them. But day after day,
we give birth, we go back to work after three months,
and then we leave our children with strangers,
in the case of daycare, at least.
And then they come home with RSV or a broken arm
or even maybe sexual trauma.
And we sit here and we wonder,
how could that happen? Well,
quite frankly,
it's because nobody could care for your child the way you did.
Not physiologically, not biologically,
not spiritually. So
with some of these studies that have come out
saying that it's perfectly normal for our children,
To leave us and go to daycare very early in their infancy.
I have to question, where's the common sense?
And who put out those studies?
And is it pointing us in a direction of a very biased agenda?
Lastly, I will end with this.
It is something you cannot take back.
I have chosen with my family,
to sacrifice whatever extra income I could bring
to stay home with my children.
Because if it takes the first three years,
according to these neuroscientists,
to create the best foundation for the rest of the child's life,
they've literally said, just give it the first two to three years,
and there's almost no way of messing up your child.
I would rather live without regret.
I would rather tell women this so that they can live without regret,
because at the end of the day,
it is such a short chapter.
It is such a small journey.
And even if, on the off chance we are wrong,
you didn't hurt the situation as a mother
by being there for your baby when they were born,
versus taking the risk of dropping them off with strangers
and just seeing how they turn out when they're 25.
Those are just my thoughts.